whether you missed me as much as I
missed you all you're like no the
australian chick i am back and better
than ever pity i'm back anyway messed up
it turns out the legend of zelda breath
of the wild has a pretty crappy reward
for finding all 900 cogs like literally
a crappy reward kotaku reported that
reddit user ex fates awaits x has found
all nine hundred of the leaf must
Couric's hidden throughout Hyrule
finding coax Awards you with [ __ ] seeds
which allow you to increase your
inventory space as it happens the reward
for uncovering every single one is has
tues gift which is this golden chocolate
ice cream emoji apparently it doesn't do
anything special either apart from
enabling you to make the biggest [ __ ]
has to do a dance of your choosing if
you're wondering how long a feat like
this might take you x phase awaits x has
apparently logged a hundred and seventy
two hours in breadth of the wild next up
bit of a PSA for you it turns out that
those of you with origin access allowing
you early access into Mass Effect
Andromeda will be able to play the game
even earlier than the early time you're
supposed to get access pc games n is
reporting that the origin access trial
has actually already started as of 230
p.m. PT today it was originally slated
to begin tomorrow unfortunately i'm
writing this in the past so i can't
verify but if you can shut down in the
comments whether you're early access is
unlocked i would appreciate it no word
yet on whether the xbox one EA access
trial will also kick off today
Andromeda's 10 hour trial lets you play
unlimited multiplayer but only certain
areas of the single-player ioa also
announced a companion app for android
matters multiplayer called apex HQ the
app will track your progression in the
mode displaying in folic which
characters you've unlocked and what
items and rewards you've collected it
arrives on march twenty while Andromeda
will be out for everybody on march 21st
finally it seems a system shock 3 may be
coming to consoles as well as pcs heyday
to develop a star breeze announced that
they have signed a deal with the games
developer other side
entertainment to publish System Shock 3
and bring it to quote PC and other
platforms star buri CEO bo andersson
clint said we're greatly looking forward
to bringing System Shock 32 players
worldwide in our collaboration with
other side entertainment and more
inspectors team I'll be first in line to
play it's not immediately clear what
starbreeze means by other platforms when
asked for clarification the publisher
said other exact platforms are still
pending we'll share more news about
System Shock three in the future in
addition to System Shock 3 develop a
night dive is also working on a remake
of the first game in the series after a
successful Kickstarter the system shop
remake is scheduled to release in q2 of
2018 on ps4 xbox one and pc there's also
a free demo of the opening level
available right now so grab that if you
haven't already that's everything I got
for you today do let me know what you
cared about to give us a like or
subscribe if you liked today's video and
hopefully I'll be healthy enough to see
you tomorrow